online jetzt öfter von mir weg hört man
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer zweifel games beziehungsweise
hunger games runde von der neuen app von
great also das ist die vierte map von
ihm ich bin hier mit ein paar youtube an
ich mache das einfach so dann seht ihr
ein paar die haben uns halt wieder
zusammengeschlossen und wollen nun
wieder ein wenig aufnehmen das letzte
mal welcher relativ früh gestorben
nach ein paar sekunden ich möchte das
jetzt ein bisschen besser machen denn
ich habe mit dem epstein wenig angeguckt
und ich weiß auch schon wohin ich sofort
laufen werde
nur ich hoffe dass dort die anderen
nicht hin laufen also ich wäre auf jeden
fall nicht zu den kisten der am anfang
rennen obwohl neben eigentlich weil das
werde ich nicht machen denn ich habe
eine bessere kiste gefunden und ich
würde sagen also die anderen kanäle
findet in der beschreibung blablabla
muss ich alles an
so jetzt spielen wir immer gleich raus
das dauert jetzt noch kleinen moment
weil er noch den schalter betätigen muss
der minecraft pocket der dass er alles
organisiert sondern dem server macht
gleich gehts los jeden moment jeden
moment jeden moment
schwörstadt auch okay 42
okay gut los geht's wer kommt mit einer
nach nie so ganz schnell weg ich weiß
auf jeden fall schon mal wo ich hin will
und das ist ganz gut aber ich denke
dabei noch anderen laufen ja die sind
alle viel schneller als ich was sollen
das ändert verstehen nicht wie sind die
jetzt alle so schnell hochgekommen
nein aber ich denke ihr werdet gleich
schon direkt sehen wo ich hin will
nämlich hier
übrigens haben auch eine grace period
von drei minuten ungefähr damit wenig
einfach direkt jemand anderen töten und
uns ein bisschen an die kisten bedienen
können und ich muss auch schon sagen ich
entschuldige mich schon mal direkt falls
ich hier direkt am anfang sterben werde
oder irgendwie so weil dann wisst ihr
einfach ich kann so was nicht und was da
also das ist klar so nice nice nice gap
charmant schwert also es steht gleich im
chat wann diese grace period zu ende ist
und dann kann man halt andere schlagen
und töten und so weiter und ich hoffe
einfach weil verhindert dass verpennt
bin zu einem anderen vorbeigelaufen fail
aufnahme in den anderen vorbei gelaufen
draht stahl blablabla wo kann ich jetzt
schon schlagen kann ich ihn schlagen
kann ich schon gar nicht kann man nicht
lange schon leer
ich habe mir die map vorher nur ganz
kurz angeguckt und wollte mir halt nur
ganz kurz gucken wo ein paar kisten sind
habe dann eine kiste ausfindig gemacht
wurde jetzt der goldene apfel das
schwert und so weiter drin sind es läuft
einfach den hinterher
naja ok das weg das heißt ich kann mich
jetzt in ruhe umschauen
der transporterfahrer so ich hoffe mal
ein bisschen rum
ich hoffe nicht dass hier gleich im
falle ist weil eigentlich habe ich bei
hunger games sind ziemlich immer das
glück dass ich irgendwo gegen laufe und
dann will ich direkt rot und das ist in
changping tape vor gott bringt mit daten
nicht aber nicht mein level noch eine
minute bis zum pvp start bisschen was
ich schaue mich erst mal ganz kurz und
ich möchte mich nicht direkt am anfang
sterben das ist halt wieder sondern
community projektes haben wir schon mal
gemacht da bin ich allerdings an alle
die das jetzt nicht wissen dass er auch
schon ein paar monate her
bei diesem anderen community projekt das
wir damals gemacht hatten in der zweiten
survival gameslab wenig losgelaufen zu
den kisten sparka man hat mich getötet
und dann war das vorbei für mich was im
verhältnis einer der insider wissen dass
dark soul
ich kenne die meisten hier gar nicht
dabei sind jetzt auf dem handy vibriert
sie sind das auch focus sendet wir
wieder das irgendwo im vatikan krieges
und sowas
so sind mir zwei grad nicht rehna games
wichtiger was der da unten hat fast gar
nicht wisst ihr was noch eine minute bis
zum tv bierstadt ich laufe jetzt einfach
mal runter bzw ich hoffe dass er hier
hochkommt irgendwie komme ich jetzt
irgendwie wieder raus ok zehn sekunden
noch
bis zum pvp staat sonst denke ich erst
mal
er kommt zu mir der kommt zu mir ich
muss gar nicht noch der luft weg du
scheiße das wäre geil so prosperierende
bahn konterkariert war der erste kinder
nicht ergebnis gemacht habe also so in
unserem games hier so ich habe aber
irgendwie auch angst dass ich jetzt hier
auslaufe ob diese kiste das habe ich
gesehen dass erfolg vorbeigelaufen
naja gut hilfe brauche ich definitiv
ich traue mich jetzt einfach mal raus
ich finde eigentlich mehr so der
vorsichtige spieler war zu was angeht
und gleich kann ich eh nicht mehr
sprinten so schnell türen zu ich bin
hier nicht nein ich bin hier nicht da
hinten sind welche aber die sollen sich
erstmal schön klappen ich hole mir
erstmal sicher die kisten nix drin
sehr schön sonst ist ja aber glaube ich
auch nix hoffe ich doch dass noch etwas
über sehr hierher sein auto parkt
phoenix ist das finde ich hat er richtig
verdient nein jetzt nicht weil ich hier
als sparkasse sondern weil er mich das
letzte mal als erstes gekeltert ist das
eine kiste übrigens ob tief eines
erlaubt allerdings maps nicht also mini
maps sollte man vielleicht auch noch
zusammen was auf und hoch oder so ich
mein was bringt das wenn man hier so
häuser gebaut dass sie eigentlich mit
decodern dann frage ich mich immer was
hat bringt das was bringt das verstehe
ich nicht naja gut gehen wir ein stück
weiter ich gebe hier ein bisschen
kompakter hinten
hatte so dürfte er noch nicht meinen
namen sehen oder erwarte ich laufe jetzt
einfach mal daher online jetzt öfter von
mir weg hört man da oben ist auch noch
einer
achtung scheiße ich lass dir erstmal in
ruhe jetzt auf der kiste war
hundertprozentig schon einmal hat man
doch schon immer ein bisschen adrenalin
wenn man hier so einen typen sieht der
kann jetzt glücklich schätzen dass a-tec
laufen konnte weil ich glaubte den kampf
gewonnen
oh gott oh gott oh gott oh gott oh gott
wer gold rüstung
wisst ihr was ich dränge mich einfach
hier so durch den wald zu dem ich hoffe
mal nicht dass der hier ist ich glaube
ich habe in diesem video mache ich
allgemeinen die musik ein bisschen
lauter welcher wenig rede
da hat den flughafen da sind aber schon
wahrscheinlich alle kisten weg allgemein
sind glaube ich schon fast alle kissen
weg und ich muss jetzt mit den sachen
auskommen die ich hier habe wenn ich
pilze finden wäre es natürlich
formidabel allerdings wage ich das zu
bezweifeln
ich laufe einfach mal noch ein bisschen
rum das gefühl ich könnte auch machen
das eher selten gemacht also wie raid
mit seinem team das hier irgendwo im
niemandsland oma kisten stehen sollten
weil man läuft hier so rum und hier
steht einfach nichts ich stehe nur in
irgendwelchen auffälligen gebäuden oder
in irgendwelchen auffällige konstruktion
aber einfach so niemandsland wenn man
die rumläuft und denke ich gar nichts
und sich war sie einfach nur versteckt
das war dann auch in wo die kiste ist
das finde ich aber ganz interessant und
ich hoffe einfach dass mich jetzt dann
zieht ich werde da hinten jetzt nochmal
zu den häusern laufe und dass dahin ein
bisschen abkoppeln basti xos lane
skripte wars lane so dass die gäste
was die gags kenn ich skripte kenne ich
glaube nicht kilian ist von fox media
krasse typen mag ich sehr
david und ich nix drin sein
wer gott da oben drauf ist glaube ich
noch eine kiste aber ich traue mich
nicht was ich kann einfach kurz im chat
fragen wie viele leben noch doppelpunkt
deckel crafter smiley okay ich hoffe
mich sieht keiner
1234 also nehmen wir noch 35
ich will gar nicht wissen wir noch alles
lebt das sind sich dem noch fast alle
und ich fühle mich jetzt schon sehr toll
dass ich ein bisschen länger als paar
minuten überlebt haben oder welche hier
wieder ihr getötete hier steht auch noch
eine kiste aber dies auch schon leer
eventuell ich kann ja mal da oben die
kiste weil sie auch nicht auf die schon
geholt wurde die habe ich mir verhindert
der fail aufnahme table tennis camps
lernen mein wichtig glaubt er ist
einfach so ein typ der der kanzel vorher
die komplette map angeguckt weil der
kampf worin auch schon mit ganz vielen
op sachen und so weiter der hat mich
vorhin dieser probe testaufnahmen runde
dings getötet und leute hätten ganz ganz
spannendes spiel
ach du scheiße
der duster rüstung als ich und alles
mitten hinein ich auch seine schritte
direkt vor mir
ach du scheiße
das mci expert
oh gott jetzt sind wir alle vier spieler
wirklich auf einem haufen ich hoffe
nicht dass der typ noch hinterher rennt
naja ich bin tot super naja als nicht so
toll also diese aufnahme aber ich denke
ich schreibe ein total genervt 1 mai der
lenker ich bin voll traurig naja es ist
halt einfach so dass manche leute mich
keine hobbys und gucken sich die map
wirklich vorher anfliegen überall rum wo
sind kisten also jetzt lud lp hat das
global players oder keine ahnung der
heiße draht gemacht nein mich hat das
auf jeden fall auch gemacht weil die
sofort weg zu kisten grad sind sofort
diamant schwert und als möglicher hatten
finde ich jetzt nicht so toll
na ja ich würde sagen ich beende für
hier erstmal die aufnahme die map ist
allgemein sehr klein gehalten und ich
bin halt ein bisschen später als letztes
mal gestorben aber es sind doch nicht
mehr ganz so viele drin ich glaube es
dennoch vielleicht 444 drei vier leute
drin
unsere vierten platz oder dritten platz
belegen finde ich schon das für mich
eine leistung
ich würde mich frau welche personen
leben doch jetzt ist er interessant 1 23
hier sei es jetzt den fünften platz
gemacht okay gut fünfter platz sind wir
zufrieden von irgendwie ich glaub 20
leute waren dabei ich würde einfach
sagen wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
mal vielleicht werden wir das noch
irgendwann aufnehmen hier ist noch der
bastille keks
na ja eventuell nehmen wir noch eine
runde auf oder irgendwann später nochmal
ich würde mich freuen wenn es wie mit
einem daumen hoch bewerten findet wenn
es euch gefallen hat wenn nicht dann mit
einem daumen runter und bis zum nächsten
mal